BOSTON BRUINS GO TO SLEEP HERE
THEY THINK, I DON'T
BATTLES, MAKAK
EFFECTIVE FOURTH LINE
GETTING THE D MAN INVOLVED IN
THERE IS PASTRNAK, HAT
TRICK.
THE THIS
GOAL.
NOT JUST THE GOAL
T. LOUIS, THEY'RE NEW.
>> Bryan: ADING
SCORE AND MONTREAL HAS THE 1-0
ADVANTAGE.ET CONTROL AND SOMEHOW
THE DEFENSE OF THE E  ONCE
PLAYOFF TIME COMES.THE FORECHEC
AND CAUSING ON TRAIL TO COUGH UP
THE PUCK. THE
RIGHT OF KNIGHT. GETS HIS
STICICLEAR GOT IT ALONG THE WAL
AND BENNETT TIPS THE  AND TO WA.
DEFENSIVE ZONE.
NOT A CLEAN HAND
BOB: RADULOV BRINGS IT
RADULOV.
YOU CAN SEE IT
INTERCEPTED BY BRADY SKJEI AND
CAROLINA IS ON SKJEI WHO KEEPS E
PLAY ALIVE AND THEN MAKES THE
PLAY HAVE THE
LEAD.
A POWER-PLAY GOAL.
BY AHO, WADE WOULD HINTZ
>> THE PERFECT SHOT GOING.
ROBERTSON AND AS I MENTIONED
THEY WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH COMK
TO BAIL OUT HRONEK   PAST GAGNE
GAINS THE ZONE, IN THE SLOT FOR
NELSON, AND HE
HITTING ANDERS LEE  NOT
SOROKIN.
NO CHANCE FOR THE GOALTENDETHE
VRANA,MAKING IT WITH STREAK CLEN
BEHIND THE OTTAWA RIGHT.
IT WILL BE DOUBLE DIGITS A AT'S
ALWAYS GREAT TO
FRONT, PARKS IT, KEEPS HIS STICK
LOOSE AND ABL RACES.
NICE PLAY BY JOSEPH.ACKHAND AND
HELLEBUYCK COULDN'T REACH IT.
TKACHUK BACK WITH IT.AY AS WELL
CONNOR HELLEBUYCK THROWS HIS
GLOVES UP IN DISGUST. IT IN
HOPING FOR A BABA 40 ON THE YEA
>> HE IS FIRST P GET ONE
MORERE HIS MOM'S HOMETOWN.. THE
RIGHT.
THTHENESS.
DROPS IT OFF, ONE TIMER,
DOING
ABOUT, POSSESSION, DRIVING
PLAYS. FROM KEITH
YANDLE AND IT GOES ONTO THE
STICK AND
JUST LIKE THAT, IT IS A
RESPONSE.
WHERE HE HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION, ONE WAY OR THE OTHER..
BO HORVAT HAD THAT PUCK COME
RIGHT TO HIM ABOUT THE
GLOVE.
>> John: RIGHT OFF THE STICK
WELL.
>> AND WE HAVE ZUCCARELLO, OVER
TO
GREAT JOB, TURNING THE PUCK OVES
ONE WILL HAVE THE LEAD.
3 THE MINNESOTA WILD SHOOTINGIEE
IT GO.T
AND THAT IS STRAIGHT TEAMS.
RIGHT OFF OF THERIGHT, WOULD HA
DRAISAITL ON A BREAKAWAY THERE
ON THA TIMO MEIER,
GREAT PATIENY
THE SPEED OF MCLEOD, IT'S AAFTER
ZACK KASSIAN HERE, PATIENCE JacD
TO REDIRECTS THIS
ONE HOME.
GETS INTO A SPOT,W TIMO MEIER H
THAT SLOT.
HERE'S THE HELP FROM
DRAISAITL, BARRIE, BUMPER BACK
TO BARRIE, BACK TO HIS GOALTEND,
MCDAVID SEES THE OPEN NET,
DISHES OFF, KANE SHOOTS AND
OILER TENURE.
PATRICK HALF A
STRIKE BEHIND
TREVOR MOORE WITH A SHORTHANDED
GOAL FOR THE SECOND STRAIGHT MO.
ALEX DEBRINCAT CONNECTS HERE.
DEBRINCAT HAS JUST BEEN AS GOOD
COMES AWAY WITH IT. THE PUCK
RADDYSH.
THAT IS HIS MEN WITH THE PUCK.
AROUND THROUGH THE SEAT OF YEAR
A SCORELESS STREAK OF OVER 121
MINUTES.
SUPPORT BY STEPHENSON YAN MARK,
A GREAT LITTLE D WIDE.
NICK WAUGH, THE RECOVERY,
MARCHESSAULT THROWS IT.
AND THEN, HE JUST
THEY WILL
THEY WERE SO GOOD.
ABLE TO SPEND THAT BACK PASS,
THROUGH STEPS
HE'S WAITING FOR THIS EXACT
THING TO HAPPEN THAN A PERFEC,
AND
WALKS DOWN.
YOU SEE HIM MARCHESSAULT.  PLAY
AND, EICHEL'S ABILITY.
DADONOV, AND THEY